bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct sur avis de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir l'europe face à
l'ukraine les vingt-sept sont parvenus
finalement à se mettre d'accord pour se
passer du pétrole russe mais à quel prix
viktor orban a joué les maîtres
chanteurs la hongrie échappe à l'embargo
et le nouveau paquet de sanctions contre
la russie masquent mal les divisions au
sein de l'union alors pourquoi l'europe
ne fait elle pas plus pour le cren c'est
la question de notre grand débat ce soir
notre grand témoin est de retour avec
ses mémoires doute revit aux édition de
l'observatoire c'est le deuxième somme
600 pages et un sous titre malgré tout
on l'a fait on l'a dit point
d'exclamation l'événement du jeudi en
1984 puis marianne dix ans après ils
rateront dans un style endiablé un
parcours de patrons de presse avec des
victoires mais aussi des doutes et
parfois des déroutes jean françois kahn
est avec nous ce soir enfin nous allons
ouvrir une page spéciale sur les
législatives dans la dernière partie
avec céline bracq notre partenaire doxa
qui va nous révéler les enseignements de
son dernier baromètre et puis le carnet
de campagne des législatives avec elsa
monde un gars va ça s'appelle les 177
ont t on est à moins de deux semaines du
premier tour et c'est parti au delà
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs
merci d'être au rendez-vous bonsoir jean
françois kahn très heureuse de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau vous étiez venu
pour vos propres le premier tome des
mémoires doute revues aux édition de
l'observatoire et c'est le deuxième tome
est comme le premier ça se dévore à
toute vitesse c'est haletant c'est
passionnant c'est un parcours voilà
d'une vie dédiée à la presse alors le
deuxième tome ça commence en 1984
l'événement du jeudi pour raconter toute
sa création va y revenir longuement puis
ensuite il ya marianne ça dit beaucoup
de choses aussi sur les relations entre
les médias et le pouvoir et puis aussi
sur le débat public contemporain parce
que voilà ça fait écho vous nous direz
s'il ya des invariants aussi ça a
beaucoup beaucoup changé on en parle
dans un tout petit instant mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est bruxelles puisqu'elle
s'est jouée cet après midi avec cet
accord
quand le président réélu français dits
historiques il y a deux mois personne ne
pensait envisageable là les sanctions
sur le pétrole russe et beaucoup de
dirigeants étaient devant vous en disant
jamais on touchera au pétrole et au gaz
c'est sûr c'est pourquoi ce sixième
paquet est historique voilà un nouveau
paquet de sanctions historique vous
allez nous dire s'il est véritablement
historique bonsoir roland lescure joie
merci d'être là vous êtes député la
république en marge des français
d'amérique du nord on dirait public en
marche vous êtes député mais vous êtes
candidats ensemble la nouvelle grande
formation politique
vous êtes en campagne pour les français
d'amérique du nord gelée dit bonsoir
richard werly bonsoir myriam ravi de
vous retrouver correspondant france
europe pour le média suisse blick et
visage familier de cette émission marica
partage chercheuse à l'ifri va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant les
spécialistes de l'allemagne également
des pays de l'est mais d'abord stéphane
pour nous planter le décor de ce sommet
européen que s'est-il dit et sur quoi
at-il abouti si j'ai bien compris votre
billet tout de suite
[Musique]
alors on y va si j'ai bien compris
l'europe ce soir c'est l'hymne à la joie
l'europe est restée unie face à la
russie et pourtant ce n'était pas gagné
c'est quand même un mois qu'on parle de
projet d'embargo sur le pétrole russe
mais hier encore la présidente de la
commission c'est la van der leyen disait
ou allah c'est pas gagné dans 48 heures
ça sera pas fait on n'y arrivera pas
pendant le sommet à tel point que donc
volodymyr alinsky qu'ils aient pu
s'exprimer devant les médias européens
c'était sa grande inquiétude hier l'idée
qu' une fois de plus l'europe soit
divisée
il faut mettre fin à toutes les
querelles en europe des querelles
internes qui ne font qu'encourager la
russie a exercé de plus en plus de
pression sur me sur l'ensemble de
l'europe le sixième paquet de sanctions
doit être adopté il doit être efficace y
compris pour le pétrole lucian a
alors fait c'est surtout la hongrie 1
qui bloquait fait cet acord embargo sur
le pétrole russe alors pas pour prendre
la défense de viktor orban rassurez vous
mais quand même faut le comprendre nous
c'est 10% du pétrole qui vient de russie
en france en hongrie c'est 65 % du
pétrole qui vient de russie par oléoduc
donc j'imagine qu'ils ont été privés de
cette ressource est absolument
dévastateur pour la russie d'autant
qu'elle n'a pas d'accès à la mer donc
c'est compliqué de se faire livrer du
pétrole par bateau dans ces conditions
donc hirshhorn irby tort aux rebelles
était un peu comme perçu la banda
relayeur nisand alors là c'est encore là
ça sera sans nous on écoute
la position hongroise est très simple
que l'énergie est un problème sérieux et
pas un jeu d'enfant c'est sérieux
possible mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
des solutions et ensuite j'ai sanctions
nous sommes prêts à soutenir le sixième
paquet s'il existe une solution pour la
sécurité de l'approvisionnement
énergétique hongrois de sécurité ça veut
dire que c'est ces organes qui a cédé
puisqu'un accord a été trouvé mais pas
du tout l inverse c'est l'union
européenne qui a préféré céder 2 or
banon lui axé en les incarnant
l'autorisation de ce continent se
fournir
en pétrole russe pour une durée que je
ne dirais pas illimitées mais dont on ne
voit pas bien la limite aux non
déterminée on va dire ben date butoir
qui est un peu agaçant ckd paix qui
faisait preuve de meilleures volontés la
slovaquie n'a pas de fin très dépendant
du pétrole russe n'a pas d'accès à la
mer pourtant il avait dit ok 18 mois ont
fait un effort pour ça donc pourquoi pas
la hongrie d'autant que ce qui agace
encore un peu plus c'est que le pétrole
russe est moins cher que les autres
pétrole donc les hongrois vont continuer
à soutenir gagnant gagnant pour un chien
alors que les autres pays de l'europe
vont devoir faire un effort peut-être
même de subir le courroux la hausse des
cours excluons l'idée que les ombres en
revanche de pétrole russe en faisant du
bénéfice là ça serait vraiment pas cool
là là ça serait très
donc on peut s'agacer de l'attitude de
la hongrie n'empêche que l'embargo
finalement il sera respecté on peut le
dire le global et manque globalement
positif mais oui je crois qu'on peut le
dire donc d'abord l'union européenne
afrique une batterie de sanctions
soixante oligarques de plus qui vont les
avoirs seront gelés des télés russes les
trois dernières sans doute qu'ils seront
interdites de diffusion la plus grosse
banque russe qui n'a plus accès à swift
on sait pas bien ce que c'est mon a
compris que
donc et puis surtout même si la hongrie
a fait beaucoup de résistance sur 7 pour
empêcher cet embargo lambris s'apaisent
pas si lourd en europe quand les 26
autres sont à peu près d'accord ça fait
quand même un vrai poids de l'embargo du
pétrole et coûte cher michel qui donne
les résultats chiffrés je rappelle qu'en
belge 75 ses 75 et que 90 c'est 90 pour
être très clair ça veut dire qu'il y a
immédiatement à un pas de 75 % du
pétrole russe qui est visé par cette
mesure et cela veut donc dire qu'avant
la fin de l'année près de 90% du pétrole
russe était importée sur le plan
européen sera visé par cette mesure
moignard ce qu'on peut dire que cet
embargo sur le pétrole russe c'est un
coup dur pour la russie brain and hove
nous experts à 6 il ya déjà eu en tout
cas un arbre un embargo sur le charbon
et du coup le chardon russe aida et
coûter moins cher et maintenant lundi
tient l achète plus de charbon russe
donc on peut imaginer que la russie peut
trouver en tout cas d'autres clients
au-delà des conséquences sur la russie
mais aussi des conséquences pour
l'europe ça aussi des conséquences cet
embargo pour nous donc on va voir le bon
côté des choses on va rester de bons
européens oui c'est excellent ça va nous
permettre d'accélérer notre recherche de
dépendance énergétique et puis pas
seulement ça a plein d'autres avantages
cet embargo on écoute le président
français macron cet objectif
d'indépendance va aussi se faire en
n'oubliant pas que certes sortir du gaz
russe est une bonne chose mais ça ne
remplace pas la sortie du gaz en
totalité pour aller vers le renouvelable
et le nucléaire qui sont des manières de
produire de l'électricité en n'émettant
pas de gaz à effet de serre donc soyons
positifs cet embargo son pétrole ses
bonbons climat à long terme à court
terme il va falloir continuer avec
l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat effectif
à savoir si ça peut permettre d'arrêter
la guerre là je n'ai pas d'opinion je
laisse les experts merci merci beaucoup
stéphane pour cet éclairage vous étiez
positif peut être à peut-être un peu
plus négatifs pour contrebalancer roland
laisse que les américains ont arrêté
d'importer du pétrole russe c'était en
mars dernier nous on a mis plusieurs
mois avant de réussir à trouver cet
accord c'est sans la hongrie et de toute
façon cet accord il commence qu'à partir
de la fin d'année est-ce qu'on manque
pas un peu de courage parce qu'à ce que
ce qu'endurent les ukrainiens le prix du
courage c'est aussi le prix de la
facture cir pour les états unis arrêter
d'importer du pétrole russe c'est
absolument rien cet accord il commence
pas en fin d'année 70 % du pétrole russe
c'est le temps qu'on traduise les
conclusions du conseil européen dans les
deux trois jours qui viennent donc il ya
70% s'est tout de suite effectivement
pour arriver à 92% qui est en gros la
totalité sauf la hongrie il faudra
attendre la fin de l'année et juste pour
donner l'accès historique vraiment
utiliser ce mot 2021 il y avait 36 % du
pétrole de l'union européenne qui naît
de la russie donc on se prive de 36 % de
notre pétrole qui va falloir aller
trouver ailleurs évidemment donc oui
c'est une contrainte historique pour
l'europe et par ailleurs du côté russe
c'est à peu près 190 milliards les
recettes de pétrole russe par an et on
voit laurent retirer à peu près 70
milliards donc près de 40 % donc oui
c'est un effort historique pour l'europe
et même s'il arrive à rediriger un peu
ça va être une contrainte très forte
pour la russie les recettes de pétrole
c'est plus que le gaz on a beaucoup
parlé du gaz et ça va être compliqué
celui la neige jusqu'au la main sur le
pétrole n'en sais c'est un gros effort
de l'europe je pense qu'il contraintes
très fortes en voir les conséquences est
vraiment si ça peut asphyxier
financièrement
la gare en ukraine comment vous voyez
les choses réservé les comment vous
appréciez cet accord qui franchement a
mis du temps à accoucher si j'ose dire
avec avec ce viktor orban qui joue un
peu les maîtres chanteurs whisky ce qui
est très intéressant dans ce qui s'est
passé à bruxelles c'est qu'au fond on a
compris que le soutien de victor hörmann
haut à ce paquet de sanctions
éventuellement à d'autres sanctions
ultérieures il faudra l'acheter il
disons les choses comme elles sont
l'union européenne va devoir payer pour
que les sanctions soient appliquées par
la hongrie parce que dans ce cas va dire
toi concrètes aiguë des écoutes et
victor o man quand il dit devant les
journalistes
il faut des solutions pour prendre des
sanctions les solutions ça veut dire
quoi je suis prêt à me passer
éventuellement du pétrole russe mais
c'est l'union européenne qui devra
trouver les solutions donc les
infrastructures les aventures
énergétique qui permettront soit
d'acheminer du pétrole venu d'ailleurs
par l'europe en tout cas si ce qu'ils
demandent et je trouve que là il y a
quelque chose de profondément choquant
parce que à aucun moment victor ban qui
encore une fois n'a pas rompu la
solidarité européenne c'est important de
le dire vous avez raison mais à aucun
moment il ne parle d'europe et de
défense de l'europe il ne parle que de
défendre les intérêts de la hongrie est
dans un contexte comme celui ci c'est
absolument choquant et je crois que là
il y à un moment où je mon pronostic
c'est qu'on va arriver avec une crie à
une crise avec des taureaux ban l'union
européenne ne peut pas continuer à ce
point d'être en quelque sorte mis devant
le fait accompli par un dirigeant qui a
pour seul souci de protéger son pays qui
dans ses médias dit en permanence je
protège les hongrois il s'agit pas de
protéger les hongrois il s'agit de
protéger les européens est d'aider les
ukrainiens au passage c'est quand même
très très important bonsoir marica
partage et bienvenue sur ce plateau ravi
de vous retrouver vous êtes chercheuse à
l'ifri spécialiste de l'allemagne et des
pays d'europe centrale quand on regarde
les dépendances des différents pays
européens au pétrole russe très
clairement la hongrie et la pologne qui
elle va être soumise à l'embargo qui l'a
souhaité c'est ce sont les plus grands
dépendants 65% soit 2 6% l'allemagne
aussi 42% c'est vrai que la france et
c'est beaucoup moins c'est 9% vous
comment vous comprenez le jeu de la
hongrie par rapport à celui de la
pologne qui avec la même dépendance deux
positions différentes
je pense que ce conflit a montré qu' il
y as d'une côté les pays d'europe
centrale et orientale auquel appartient
la pologne qui voit aussi une certaine
solidarité envers l'ukraine et qui aussi
voit l'importance du lien
transatlantique dont il ya un
resserrement des liens entre les états
unis et servane des propos qui no 6 kg
et est reparti
avec avec la russie effectivement peu ce
qu'on peut rappeler le fait que avant
l'éclatement de la guerre est bien
viktor orban s'est rendu chez vladimir
poutine pour négocier des prix gaziers
plus favorable pour la hongrie alors que
les troupes russes se massaient déjà aux
frontière avec l'ukraine donc voilà
c'est quand même ça la situation en
hongrie ya par ailleurs aussi une
proximité avec la chine par exemple 1
donc effectivement avec l'université de
fudan avec donc ce
campus lors il est dedans pour les
avantages mais en même temps tourné vers
l'extérieur d'actes manqués c'est une
question de souveraineté roi vers la
chine et la russie quand ça l'arrangé
c'est une question de ne pas abandonner
sa souveraineté par rapport à une
souveraineté qui serait jean françois
kahn comment vous regardez ça on les
américains ils ont décidé un embargo dur
sur sur le pétrole bien longtemps mais
par exemple les italiens ont décidé
d'arrêter leur importation de gaz là je
parle du gaz c'est encore autre chose
mais c'est la dépendance est forte et
ils l'ont fait unilatéralement tout seul
pour montrer l'exemple et nous à 27 ça
prend des mois et finalement on se rend
compte qu'ils viennent et une dérogation
c'est d'autant plus
étonnant aux courageux
que
en hongrie où il a gagné les élections
il ya quelques mois s'il y'avait nous
élections il égalerait encore mieux
alors que beaucoup de pays qui viennent
de défier l'embargo les perdrais pour
cette raison pour pas se raconter des
blagues il est paré pour cette raison je
me souviens on disait à une époque comme
quand on dit quelque chose tout le monde
dit la même chose au même moment donc
tout le monde disait finalement la
guerre du grain est une aubaine pour mac
rend la vérité sur la guerre d'ukraine
est un chemin de croix on m'a cran c'est
à dire l'inflation la hausse des prix
le prix du pétrole la fin de la
croissance et les troubles au stade de
france parce que c'est aussi une
conséquente dans la mesure où ça devait
avoir lieu à saint pétersbourg etc etc
ça a été rapatrié en france
voilà moi ce que je pense
c'est que il ya un phénomène en russie
dmitry daddies à sion si aujourd'hui
tout à coup vous avez envoyé d'ukraine
pas tout il ya deux mois ou trois mois
on avait dit voilà on prend des
sanctions n'aident claire's aurait des
répercussions terribles sur la
population russe sur l'opinion mais ça
fait trois ans quatre ans cinq ans que
tous les six mois on va des sanctions
contre la russie c'est une faute
formidable donc d'abord ça ça endormi le
pion l'opinion russe trouve ça normal on
prend des sanctions contre lui avons
fait une réunion bayer le sanctuaire
doyen des 100 kg ont alors fait plus
d'effet d'autre part ils se sont en 3 4
mois ils se sont préparés se sont mis
tri d'étatiser ils se sont adaptés aux
sanctions je pense que la voir
multiplier comme ça pendant des années
les sanctions et maintenant ça retire
une grande partie d'efficacité qui
aurait été radical si on les hait prix
qu'on réponde
réponse à n'importe quoi juste lescure
mais j'entends ce que dis-je en
trois mois les plaquettes sanction je
trouve ne pouvoir pas forcément la
situation a beaucoup changé ce que vous
dites est vrai jusqu'à ya trois mois
l'invasion du crâne c'est à trois mois
sur le répète le pétrole russe et 36 %
du pétrole importé par l'union
européenne et en trois mois on se prive
de 90% 36% cr d'un tiers du pétrole
importé en europe et trois mois à l'aune
de l'histoire trois mois à l'aune d'un
conflit qui malheureusement va durer
c'est pas grand chose tout ça
effectivement pourquoi pour garder
l'europe unie et pour aller assez fort
sur des voies de sanctions tout en
essayant de trouver des voies de
contournement notamment pour la pologne
et d'autres qu'est ce que vous répondez
réservé les gardes et l'europe unie à
quel prix jusqu'où donc d'abord pour
répondre à votre chroniqueur stéphane
tout à l'heure qui disait en plus il va
leur vendre à profit non ça c'est prévu
dans les conclusions donc hors ban il
n'a pas il faut aller chercher du
pétrole en russie mais peut pas leur
vendre derrière et d'autres pas
effectivement pour éviter de l'acheter
au prix fort et en gros de lui vendre du
a fallu donner du pétrole qui reçoit
aujourd'hui de la russie
en fait on signe un accord à 90% et
c'est vrai que l'europe est quasiment
unis je pense qu'on peut dire comme tel
c'est un accord unanime du sommet des
chefs d'états dont un état et un chef
d'état est exclu mais la réalité du coup
éthique et qui pose ses conditions parce
que regarder on regarde je suis pas
regarder l'oléoduc l'oléoduc qui
s'appelle djerba c'est l'eau des ducs
qui approvisionne par la russie un
certain nombre de pays dont évidemment
la hongrie ça veut dire amitié
d'ailleurs en russe ce pétrole a va
pouvoir continuer à passer dans cet
oléoduc pour les hongrois et seulement
pour eux c'est ça l'idée oui c'est à
dire quand même
et en plus de ça il dit je le ferai je
n'en sortirait que si vous me payez
entre guillemets avec un chèque européen
toutes les infrastructures permettront
de pallier au manque d'approvisionnement
la réalité du coup en partie d'ailleurs
si non c'est lui non les halls il aurait
gagné si on lui avait payé la réalité
c'est qu'on ne lit pas y peint qu'il a
été effectivement aurait il une manière
magistrale et que c'est très difficile
de dire un chef d'état aujourd'hui
extrêmement légitimement son pays tu es
gentil mais tu vas te tally au 26 et aux
terres la réalité c'est que plutôt que
de lui faire un chèque
on lui a dit bah écoute tu vas garder
ton pétrole russe les 26 autres pour 90%
du pétrole russes eux ils vont mettre la
pression aux fonctions poutine ce qui
est quand même l'essentiel l'objectif il
est aujourd'hui de réduire de manière
drastique les recettes de la russie
reste que ça marche mais en tout cas
c'est bien plus fort qu'il ya trois mois
où on go sont occupés des oligarques le
pari qu'on veille à trois mois s'est on
s'occupe des oligarques et où vont
s'occuper de poutine bon on va dire ça
c'est plutôt
la famille quand même la pression sur
les banques tout à l'heure je disais
qu'est ce que c'est que swift bas je
peux vous dire moi je connais des russes
dont les familles et notamment les
grands parents sont en russie
aujourd'hui peuvent plus lent et
d'argent c'est aussi simple que ça il ya
des gens qui vivaient de transferts de
la diaspora qui n'en vivent plus donc la
pression sur l'économie domestique russe
du fameux abandonned swift il est réel
c'est vrai que là on change de dimension
je pense qu'il ya deux dimensions
puisque vous vous en parliez il ya une
dimension politique et je répète ce que
je disais à voir un dirigeant européen
dans un contexte d'une telle crise ne
parler que des intérêts de son pays et
nous dire à son peuple qu'il est là que
pour les protéger franchement je trouve
ça inacceptable il là il y à un moment
où il va bien falloir taper sur les
nerfs changer les règles du jeu et faire
une sorte peut-être l'une était en
l'occurrence changer les règles du jeu
metal a déjà craché sur la table c'est
déjà c'est-à-dire déjà dire ça direz
vous aurez constaté que ni emmanuel
macron président en exercice européenne
bonne question parce que le moment parce
qu'on est dans un moment de crise
extrêmement aigu et que probablement
l'unité le souci des néo d'unités prix
mais il va falloir un moment donné dit
rabito roban ce que vous dites est
inacceptable ensuite il ya une dimension
économique elle est un petit peu plus
complexe et là je suis d'accord avec
monsieur lescure parce qu'à partir du
moment et il faudra le faire l'union
européenne va devoir payer pour
construire de nouvelles infrastructures
énergétiques adaptés à la nouvelle donne
énergétique c'est-à-dire à la
déconnexion du gaz et du pétrole russes
à ce moment là l'union européenne va
avoir le levier sur balles parce que à
ce moment là il y aura un donnant
donnant c'est dire si tu ne respectent
pas les règles je ne te construis pas
les infrastructures malheureusement on
n'en est pas encore là donc pour le
moment on est encore dans la phase
politique il va quand même falloir à un
moment donné que le chantage au mont
rhétorique de victor o man s'arrête
marek appartint comment il entend lui il
a pas l'air pour l'instant de redouter
trolls et les sanctions européennes déjà
sur l'état de droit qui sont encore en
cours on a l'impression que son agenda
fini par l'emporter sur janot entre
entre guillemets je pense qu'il n'y a
pas que la hongrie après y'a la
république tchèque et la slovaquie
derrière il ya la bulgarie n'ont que
pour tous ces pays il va y avoir
semble-t-il des exemptions et il ya
également en autriche grave n'est à mal
le chancelier qui a dit que c'était un
accord qui était équitable et il attend
sans doute une retour non un retour
d'ascenseur sans doute pour le gaz parce
qu'elle est riche et dépendantes à 80%
du gaz russe donc on voit que c'est
c'est complexe par rapport aux à
l'oléoduc vous mentionniez également et
bien l'allemagne a également accès à cet
oléoduc visiblement les néerlandais dans
la lhjmq la question c'est pratiquement
y aura du pétrole qui râle dans un pays
proche donc les allemands les polonais
ont déjà dit nous la manche on est
prêtes à la coupée le temps de trouver
des alternatives
heureusement l'un et l'autre ont des
côtes et donc peuvent importer du
pétrole par les côtes ça a été dit
talaris et enclavé et donc la hongrie va
garder le robinet pour son deuil de ce
qui vient de la russie mais ça va
s'arrêter à la hongrie en gros on fait
une exception hongroise pour éviter de
lui faire un gros chèque ça je suis
d'accord et la réalité c'est qu'on a
préservé la maille l'unanimité malgré un
veto quasi explicite je voudrais qu'on
parle des régions entre la france et l
ukraine mais peut-être une toute petite
question vous étiez président de la
commission des affaires économiques
très utile
vous pouvez nous donner
sorte de tableau des conséquences sur
sur des prêts à la pompe s est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre on est à 5,1 %
d'inflation les chiffres sont tombés
hier ça va là c'est un peu plus de 2
euros le litre de gazole s'attendre à
quoi bon d'abord on est alors un accueil
en france et en est à huit en allemagne
à 14 en slovénie donc il faut se
souvenir que en france au mas de
l'inflation certes mais grâce à tout ce
qu'on a fait le bouclier les 15 centimes
etc on se retrouve avec une inflation
relativement modérée par rapport au
monde entier
maintenant c'est vrai que ce type de
mesure va sans doute avoir un impact
légèrement positif sur le prix du
pétrole il est quand même largement
anticipée dire que quand vous regardez
les prix du marché du pétrole je parle
pas du prix à la pompe ils s'attendaient
déjà sans doute à ce que cet accord soit
fait parce que au fond ça faisait
suffisamment de temps qu'on en parlait
pour se dire ça allait arriver donc je
suis pas sûr que ça va avoir un impact
très important
je comprends maintenant il faut qu'on
intègre ça dans notre réflexion ça tombe
bien puisque le projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat sera présenté fin juin
ça nous donne encore un peu de temps
pour le dessiner alors on revient sur le
dossier ukrainien va s'arrêter sur les
relations entre la france et la russie
ou pour le dire autrement faut-il
continuer à parler à vladimir poutine
parce que on entend de plus en plus de
pays y compris au sein de l'union
européenne critiquer ouvertement ce lien
qu emmanuel macron semble résolu à
maintenir coûte que coûte kathia gilder
et on en reparle juste après c'est ce
que l'on appelle la diplomatie du
téléphone depuis le début de l'invasion
de l'ukraine il y a trois mois emmanuel
macron par la wla d'ymir poutine on ne
compte plus le nombre d'appels entre
paris et moscou ce samedi encore
maintenir le fil avec moscou tout en
restant du côté des ukrainiens c'est la
stratégie de paris qui s'obstinent à
vouloir jouer les médiateurs entre les
deux pays avec l'espoir d'arracher la
paix sans humilier le maître du kremlin
en vain poutine poursuit sa guerre
inflexible tandis que volodymyr elin ce
qu'ils reprochent au président français
de vouloir faire des concessions
diplomatiques à la russie il ne faut pas
chercher une porte de sortie pour la
russie et macron le fait en vain ils
voulaient obtenir des résultats mais il
n'en a pas eu la russie ne cherchera
aucune issue au conflit au sein même de
l'europe la position de paris dit vise
notamment les anciens pays de l'est le 4
avril dernier le premier ministre
polonais a sèchement recadrer la france
monsieur le président macron à combien
de reprises avez vous négocié avec
poutine qu'avez vous obtenu personne ne
doit négocier avec les criminels il faut
les combattre personne n'a négocié avec
hitler
malgré les critiques la france qui
préside l'union européenne jusqu'au 30
juin reste sur sa ligne dépêché à kiev
deux mois après les massacres de butch à
la nouvelle ministre des affaires
étrangères rappelle une nouvelle fois la
position de paris pas plus que ces
années la france est en guerre avec la
russie elle ne l'est pas et leur
engagement efforts appuyés l'ukraine en
lui apportant des équipements de défense
ce qui me semble nécessaire de se
défendre depuis son discours le 9 mai
dernier au parlement européen le
président français restent prudents
quand il a pris la parole ce jour là
c'était pour proposer une communauté
politique européenne capable
d'accueillir l'ukraine certains y ont vu
un moyen de reculer la perspective
d'adhésion de kiev jean françois kahn ce
que vous comprenez les critiques les les
les interrogations sur l'attitude de la
france continue et a parlé à poutine
même si pour le moment mais on ne voit
pas à quoi ça sert ses engage à rien
pour se faire bien voir dire wow je suis
a voulu un jour n'est à eux tout ça me
fait
me après les mots gentils on continue
dirigeants polonais dire on ne négocie
pas avec hitler parce que nous on a
essayé de trouver un compromis je vous
tiens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au
moment d horribles d épouvantable
accords de munich
les polonais ont fait feu négocié
kittler ont fait un accord avec l'ue est
claire un accord de partage la
tchécoslovaquie alors faut arrêter ça
veut pas dire que c'est un exemple
aujourd'hui si au contraire ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire enfin les gardiens qui va
moi mais là il ya des jours où bon cela
dit s'est exprimé au
sujet des 6es négocier pour donner du de
l'air à à poutine mais s'il ya une
moindre chance de négocier pour
permettre que le peuple ukrainien ne
subissent pas le martyr qu'il subit qui
peut dire il faut pas le faire tant pis
pour les polonais ça fait rien les
polonais qu'on écrase et polonais on
aura une position pur et dur c'est quand
même j'ajoute une chose à propos de
poutine il faut quand même dire les
choses parce que moi je suis se trouve
inconcevable
je voudrais bien renversez boudine
vraiment balayé et s'ils étaient
renversées et qu'il y avait des
élections libres enrichit aujourd'hui
qu'ils gagneraient
y en a voté récemment c'est d'un côté un
parti communistre c'est stalinien et de
l'autre un parti nationaliste d'extrême
droite faut arrêter de se raconter des
blagues vous savez on ne faut jamais
oublier que ce qu'ont subi les russes au
moment du gouvernement gaïdar est à dire
les libéraux au pouvoir les a tellement
obsédé pour eux un tel cauchemar comme
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas vrai qu'une
opposition tel qu'on le souhaite telle
qu'on l'aimerait 30 qui nous ressemble
ray peut gagner des élections est arrivé
au pouvoir il faut arrêter de se
raconter des blagues sur le fil du
dialogue
maintenir ou pas ce fil aujourd'hui très
très franchement on ne voit pas à quoi
ça sert qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça a
permis ces heures et 16 heures de
téléphone d'abord emmanuel macron seul
je rappelle seul président d'un pays
membres du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
au sein de l'union européenne
il est dans son rôle il est dans son
rôle en maintenant le contact et
continuer par les mêmes après juin quand
il ne sera plus président du conseil de
l'union il continuera sans doute de le
faire mais à ce moment là il ne le fera
plus au nom de l'union européenne comme
il le fait aujourd'hui mais deux
éléments le premier je crois qu'il y à
la donne humanitaire peut-on discuter
avec poutine alors qu'il est en train de
commettre des crimes affreux il y a
quand même une autre dunk et là la
realpolitik dire que s'il s'en prend à
odessa comme on peut penser qu'il a
l'intention de le faire et si son
objectif est de priver l'ukraine un
accès à la mer noire là on est dans une
situation disons le insupportable pour
l'union européenne et pour l'europe et
une ukraine enclavé c'est juste
insupportable
donc il y a et je les comparer dans un
article à kissinger je pense qu'on a un
emmanuel macron qui est en train de
réaliser comme l'a dit récemment le très
vieux henry kissinger au forum de davos
que peut-être il faut que des
concessions territoriales aient lieu
pour permettre la paix peut-être vous
allez répondre en tant que chef de
l'état il ne s'agit pas de juger mais en
tant que chef de l'état i les dans son
rôle il a il est il est compréhensible
qu'ils regardent cette équation marais
cappart assez intéressant parce que sur
cette question là parler ou pas poutine
ouvrir la porte à l'ukraine dans l'ue à
l'union européenne et avec quel
calendrier la question des livraisons
d'armes autre plus offensif plus rapide
il ya des divisions y compris au sein de
l'union les pays de l'est notamment la
pologne comprennent pas très bien la
position française et ne se prive pas de
le faire savoir
pourquoi on revient un clivage est ouest
au sein de au sein de l'union européenne
une partie des groupe delhaize tourner
vers les états unis
certainement et puis je pense qu une
proximité géographique aussi qui fait
que en pologne on comprend bien cette
menace par rapport à la russie en france
on est un peu plus éloigné de ce débat
là mais plus globalement je pense que on
fait le constat aujourd'hui est d'une
architecture de sécurité européenne qui
n'existe plus c'est le la charte de
paris de 1990 est le de la charte de
helsinki de 1975 aujourd'hui il s'agit
de reconstruire cela et cela passe
forcément par le dialogue et la question
qui va se poser c'est comme vous l'aviez
évoqué la question des frontières est ce
que le voilà est-ce que l'ukraine va
être enclavé est ce qu'elle pourra
rester comme elle l est comment ça se
passe et l'approvisionnement du pays
également
évidemment il ne faut rien imposé à
l'ukraine il faudra le laisser décider
mais c'est aussi la realpolitik qui joue
et il faut la realpolitik ça peut pas
être une victoire de l'ukraine c'est ma
question est ce qu'à un moment donné à
chaque fois au poutine a recommencé il
l'a fait en tchétchénie de la fin mais à
chaque sou l'histoire enfin bioméca
crimée est ce que est ce que cette fois
là il faut à nouveau préparer la paix en
imaginant une partition possible la
réponse course et personne n'en sait
rien aujourd'hui et donc moi j'ai plutôt
envie de poser la question suivante
qu'est-ce que ça dessert le fait qu
emmanuel macron par la poutine il n'a
fait aucune concession il l'a dit tant
que monsieur zelensky ne me demande pas
d'en faire je n'en ferai pas et la
poussée aux sanctions en plus et il a en
même temps coup cela plus est les
tensions sanctions l'allemagne a enfin
accepté d'augmenter son budget militaire
on a créé un front 10 milliards de
concret un embryon d'europe de la
défense donc c'est quoi le problème en
fait c'est quoi le problème de continuer
à parler à bladimir pour gagner ainsi
douché les espoirs de craine tournés
vers l'europe en disant ça prendra des
années voire des décennies c'est de dire
les revenus immédiats sion ni esprit de
revanche il va falloir discuter avec la
russie au moment où vous les ukrainiens
sont sous les bombes oui mais la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que l'ukraine asie ce
qu'elle est aidé dans l'ain sa
résistance par les puissances
européennes y compris la france est
américaine et que par ailleurs on est en
train de resserrer très fortement les
sanctions donc les résultats c'est sain
et le reste c'est qu'on garde un canal
de communication qui pour l'instant n'a
en rien affaibli ni l'ukraine ni
l'occident moi je préfère qu'un garde
puis ensuite on verra où ça nous amène
mais voilà l'histoire est faite de
malentendus
assez délétère auquel si on peut y
échapper faisons tout pour le faire oui
de son nom personne personne ne
négociera avec poutine sur le dos de
l'ukraine bien sûr ce qu'on peut faire
de mieux c'est négocier avec poutine des
éléments que 11 juillet un mandat d et
craignent un bien sûr que ensuite on
présente à l'ukraine pour essayer de
favoriser
un compromis entre les deux il n'y a pas
d'autre solution qu'un compromis ou une
victoire totale de là où l'autre de
toute façon c'est clair c'est une
victoire totale où l'un ou l'autre ou
c'est un compromis entre les deux le
plus favorable possible à l'ukraine
réservé ligue celui en conclure celui
qui est dans son rôle c'est le président
ukrainien qui a peur de ce que dit jean
françois kahn c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné une solution se passe dans
son dos donc lui il est dans son rôle
par contre ce qui est très intéressant à
manier la courroie de communication
c'est qu'à un moment donné on aimait
bien vladimir poutine nous dise quels
sont ses objectifs
parce que pour l'instant il ne les a
toujours pas dit et donc il y as besoin
de parler avec lui pour que peut-être un
moment ils disent voilà moi je compte
m'arrêter là et c'est en fait à ce
moment là que tout débutera
vous pensez qu'on essaye dans le cas de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe ce qui a marché ce
qui n'a pas marché les accords de minsk
faire un espèce de retour d'expérience
aussi voir ce qu'on peut garder voir ce
qui est obsolète ça ça me semble assez
essentiel pour l'avenir avoir des
mesures de confiance restauré des
mesures de confiance
mesures de contrôle aux armements
également donc ça ça me semble assez
important moi je suis pessimiste préfère
me voir conclure on le sait en vérité
c'est là jamais voulu prendre kiev c'est
de la blague d'ailleurs c'est impossible
si ce qu'il veut c'est un excès ce qu'on
appelle une aubette à dire la partie
russophones de l'est et il est en train
d'y arriver et donc ça ça me rend très
pessimiste parce que dès lors qu'il va y
arriver je ne vois pas comment on peut
arriver à un compromis où ça nécessitera
qu'il y renonce pas ce qu'on peut qui
s'achève c'est pas quelqu'un dit ça on
peut aller jusqu'à dire écoutez vous
gardez la crimée on peut aller jusque là
on peut pas accepter qu'ils gardent le
donbass et dans la mesure où il est en
train d'occuper et de russie fier là je
suis
évidemment continuer à en parler de ce
dossier ukrainien en tout cas l'europe
fonctionne l'europe à 27 sanctionne pour
la sixième fois la russie on verra avec
quelles conséquences merci merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau de
lcp nous apporter votre éclairage jean
françois kahn c'est très en verve vous
allez rester avec moi parce qu'on doit
maintenant parler de ce tome 2 de vos
mémoires malgré tout on l'a fait on l'a
dit c'est le sous titre vous raconter la
création je le disais de l'événement du
jeudi puis de marianne votre muse
journalistes en patron presse on a plein
de questions à vous poser comme les skis
ce sujet c'est nier kathia gilder
si on vous invite jean françois kahn
c'est pour vous parler d'un monde
ébranlé par l'incertitude ou le pire est
de retour pour avoir votre regard sur la
guerre de vladimir poutine en ukraine
sur ce monde déboussolé où les pandémies
mettre les populations sous cloche
le monde jean françois kahn vous l'avez
longtemps parcouru vous avez été témoin
des événements de l'histoire en france
et à l'étranger c'est vous qui avez
révélé l'assassinât de l'opposant
marocain mehdi ben barka en 1966 à
l'époque vous étiez reporter de guerre
pour l'express vous avez vu du pays on
vous voit ici à votre retour d'union
soviétique
j'ai eu l'occasion ou personnellement de
me rendre en union soviétique
pour écrire un livre sur la révolution
d'octobre qui s'appelle tout commence à
petrograd et de rencontrer des témoins
libre penseur inclassable vous avez le
goût des mots et des polémiques en 1984
vous fondez votre propre journal
l'événement du jeudi puis marianne en
1997 qui deviendra le fer de lance de la
lutte contre la politique de nicolas
sarkozy
vous avez bien rempli votre vie ou
plutôt vos vies multiples de
journalistes éditorialistes patrons de
presse et essayiste vous êtes l'auteur
d'une quarantaine d'ouvragés de la
guerre civile en 1982 jusqu'à vos
mémoires doute review vous raconter
l'époque en ayant le courage de vos
opinions
quand on a raison on a souvent raison
contre d'autres tous les journaux
étaient pour l'intervention en libye
mettait vraiment les seuls à avoir 10
les résultats vont être calamité
l'expliquez vous on a eu raison
incontestablement il revend
la vie politique vous l'observez la
décrypter depuis près d'un demi siècle
ni de droite ni de gauche mais proche
des idées centristes vous soutenez la
candidature de françois bayrou à la
présidentielle
vous sautez même le pas en 2009 lorsque
vous vous présenter aux élections
européennes sur une liste modem vous
êtes élu mais renoncer à votre siège
vous quittez ensuite le journalisme
prenez du recul mais vous gardez un oeil
sur l'actualité et vos commentaires au
vitriol comme lorsqu'on vous demande ce
que vous pensez de la nouvelle alliance
des gauches au tour de jean luc
mélenchon c'est la première fois depuis
nulle sur 21 aux que les disciples de
blum
d'une certaine manière ronnie léon blum
des gaullistes et est prêt à s'allier
avec des pétainistes et là on a des
chaussures démocrate qui se livrent des
néo bolchevique alors justement jean
françois kahn votre regard sur cette
recomposition politique on vous pose la
question la gauche et la droite vont
elles disparaître ou bien se
reconstruire
on va on va venir à cette question dans
un dans un tout petit instant jean
françois kahn ou allez vous parler du
paysage politique actuel mais partout
quand même de cette vie dédiée à la
presse je peux faire une petite remarque
ainsi que dans le flou dans le film un
moment on voit je me suis je suis tout
jeune oui j'étais en union soviétique et
j'ai rencontré des témoins aux gens
pourquoi générant couvre pas ce que
c'est très important sur le thème de la
mémoire c'est une chose qui m'a beaucoup
interpellé sur ce thème la mémoire tout
l'été moi d'abord j'ai pas rencontré de
grands témoins qui avaient fait la
révolution bolchevique pour des raisons
que vous pouvez deviner sexta line ils
avaient tous fusillés mais c'était des
témoins des militants de base qui a fait
la révolution bolchevique
pas un seul
entendez bien pas un seul ne se
souvenait avoir vu ou entendu parler
d'un certain trotsky qui pourtant est le
type qui l'avait fait cette révolution
était omniprésent autrement dit la pro
40 ans la gande avait d après ce qu on
avait nettoyé les mémoires et ça a été
pour moi une leçon pour interpeller sa
mémoire c'est très important parce que
le elle peut avoir été elle aussi
nettoyer alors justement quelle mémoire
on a l'impression que vous avez gardé
tous vos carnets ça fourmille
d'anecdotes vous dit au début du livre
que vous avez plus aimé être
journalistes reporters sur le terrain
que patron presse j'ai pris plus de
plaisir à collaborer à des journaux
protégé par le gilet pare-balles de
l'irresponsabilité qu'elle est dirigée
alors on a du mal à vous croire
franchement parce que quand on regarde
laventure l'épopée incroyable qu'a été
la création de l'événement du jeudi on
se dit quand même dirigez vous aviez ça
dans le sang emmenez emmener des troupes
derrière vous un bon camp gelé la
création d'événements du jeudi saint
c'est l'idée de créer un journal de
grande diffusion ça a été même le
premier en vente au numéro alors j'avais
pas un sou je ne connaissais absolument
aucun banquier aucun industriel qui
avait des sous c'est de la folie aucune
banque n'a voulu vous prêtez de l'argent
qu'il ne pas à prêter mais je ne
demandais pas une banque de me prêter
d'argent c'est pire que ça c'est moi qui
quand j'ai trouvé les les trente mille
petits plus actionnaire et 30000
français qui se réfèrent lecteurs
exonéré aux banques d'accepter que que
de me servir pour vous le revendez
action c'est à dire est-ce qu'ils
acceptent qu'on verse leur argent chez
eux et c'est ce qu'il refusait
refusaient même pas de me prêter d'être
il refaisait qu'on leur apporte mon
argent ce que je disais que je vais
faire un journal à bon bah alors c'est
bien c'est très très bien donc c'est
derrière vous il ya quoi loria
rothschild ya d'assaut il ya hersant
non non non non il n'ya pas tous savent
alors y'a quoi il ya trente mille 30
mille français propriétaire regardé
comme si j'étais un gauchiste les
cheveux les voiliers gelés
et me dit votre journal il doit quelle
est sa ligne l'iba totalement
indépendant mais c'est comme si j'avais
dit une cochonnerie donc totalement
dépendant nonnon
même argent qu'on l'aura mené les débats
que tu as tellement indépendant vous le
dites immédiatement à vos lecteurs dans
l'événement du jeudi vous dites je ne
veux pas plaire à tout prix est-ce que
c'était ça le début au fond de cet
anticonformisme qui va devenir votre
lutte contre la pensée unique dix ans
après cette idée qu'au fond il ya dans
les médias une forme d'unanimité qui
finit par empêcher d'être libre oui j'ai
moi je suis pas un anti conformiste
naturel je cherche pas est
anticonformiste si je suis d'accord
l'ambiance je le dis je ne cherche pas
je suis pas un rebelle de de tempérament
mais je vous avais passé l'exemple sur
la libye ça me semble évident que
l'intervention en libye est une folie
sans
résultat calamiteux même si tout le
monde était pour j'ai dit j'ai dit que
je que c'est une folie parce que je
pensais que c'est une folie c'est pas
pour prendre le contre-pied et c'est
aujourd'hui c'est quand même
extraordinaire parce que moi pourquoi
j'ai dit on la dit pourquoi dans le six
jours lundi j'avais oublié souvent est
le nombre de choses qu'on a dit qu'on a
répété
par exemple fait que le référendum
européen sur la constitution européenne
5 j'ai voté oui enfin les français ont
voté non
on fait passer ce qu'ils ont fusé ce
qu'elle joue si bien le faire passer sur
demander leur avis on a dix à avoir des
conséquences terribles ça les gens vont
douter de la démocratie on avait raison
mais on était pratiquement seul mais le
nombre de gens maintenant qu'ils disent
comme s'il avait toujours dit ce que
nous disions pratiquement seul peux vous
dire que heureusement que j'ai
l'habitude bon alors l'événement du
jeudi vous l'avez dit va s'imposer
rapidement en tête des ventes mais en
même temps il va être frappés par un
drame un an à peine après sa création
c'est l'enlèvement de jean paul
kauffmann carton fontaine kaufmann et
sera qui vont être enlevées par le
hezbollah libanais et retenu en otage
pendant quatre ans au liban et alors là
vous raconter même si ce n'était pas
forcément une bonne chose de faire ça
vous partez là bas pour essayer de le
faire bouger les jeunes ne sais pas ce
que je me ce donjon ce sur quoi je
m'interroge c'est que nous a fait une
campagne continuer continuer en a mais
qu'il n'a pas eu le soin de rappeler qui
était l'une des plus main de l'homme
alors on a fait vraiment une pression
grâce à la sa femme qui a été formidable
et je m'interroge au jury est ce qu ont
eu raison
est ce qu'on n'a pas fait monter le prix
j'ai aussi vrai ou bien faut bien voir
votre moi j'ai été au liban alors je
compte extraordinaire j'ai été enlevé
c'est un grand mais dans les fêtes et
des laisses bolat son arrivée je me
regardais une affiche qui me prennent
ils mènent dans une boîte heures
voitures budget dans une voiture ils
m'emmènent un endroit je pas où là il me
bande les yeux il me pousse dans une
pièce alors j'ai l'impression c'est une
pièce noire mais comme j'avais apporté
peut-être qu'elle n'est pas noir et là
il ya un type une voix absolument un
français impeccable qui m'interroge
comme un commissaire de police et donc
qui je suis où je vais enfin tout tout
tout tout bon très bien comment ça la
trouille on me pousse dans une pièce à
côté là on m'enlève le le bandeau et il
ya quatre types avec des mitraillettes
kalachnikov sur le sur les genoux qui
sont là sont rébarbatifs u10 et horia
bon hiver mais peut-être qu'ils vont
garder aussi vont regarder combien de
temps etc puis j'entends un moment ils
discutent et j'en entends un qui passe
de belmondo pour pourquoi il parlait le
moment là je voulais vous sautez sur
l'occasion et vous j'aimais beaucoup
belmondo lui dit vous savez je connais
très bien belmondo ce qui est absolument
pas vrai je ne connais absolument pas
mais le monde mais jusqu'en est très
très bien mais le monde aux abois oui je
connais très bien dit mais c'est lui qui
fait ses cascades avant oui ça je peux
vous dire j'ai assisté c'est lui tout
seul qu'il faisait et à partir du moment
où on a pu briser la vitre commandé par
des bêlements dos un dialogue un
dialogue et finalement ils m'ont
vraiment relâchée au bout d'une heure
il ya des anecdotes comme ça quasiment à
tous et à toutes les pages ce qu'on
retient de l'événement et de l'événement
du jeudi et de marianne c'est les unes
parce que c'est vrai qu'elles ont fait
beaucoup parler elles vous ont valu
beaucoup de procès en fait tout laisser
ça là qu'est ce qui fait qu'on décide au
fonda les titres et les cons ou titres
et les ou titre est sûre alors
sur sarkozy le voyou de la république
s'était pas vous parce que vous n'y
était plus mais quand même
c'était dans ce que les villes de france
ce rappel est ce que vous dites me pose
un problème parce que on a fait en effet
une sur les cons mais c'était un truc
c'était dans mon idée c'était vraiment
faire un dossier d'abord sur les
savez que c'est incroyable je sais ton
nez en mois d'août au mois d'août on
fait les francs maçons ou nounous mais
les francs maçons est ce que vous voulez
pas faire les marronniers qu'avait
marronniers les machins les
francs-maçons le enfin et tous le
salaire des cadres et au mois d'août
souvent une information comme quoi des
kurdes sont arrivés dans un village
kurde ailleurs de turquie hélas sont
livrés à un massacre et tous couchés
mais comment les opprimés peut devenir
si vite au près mais oppresseurs comment
les martyrs peut faire des martyrs et
j'ai pensé au concept vous voyez
sartrien du séno essais je décide de
faire de une sur cette idée là
d'ailleurs le lac ouvertes c'était
saddam hussein le premier dont on
parlait et maintenant c'est devenu le
type de la une démagogie
alors que c'était pas ça alors du coup
on a fait les cons parce que c'est un
vrai
c'est un sujet c'est moi sur sarkozy
quand même à sauver des phases chappat
sur la une mais vous avez des pages vous
vous dites au fond qu'il avait mis tous
les journalistes dans sa poche que vous
essayez lui-même de de s'approcher de
vous de vous séduire et vous n'avez
jamais cédé non je n'ai pas de mérite de
ça il a si non non il a pu s'approcher
tout le monde pour les séduire c'est
normal pour un homme politique
vous savez entre nous
ce qu'on disait sur le tableau rim est
arrivé dire du bien sarkozy par exemple
au moment de la crise jeunes et anciens
qui n'a fait preuve de dynamisme
d'inventivité etc mais ce conte sur quoi
on assiste
on assiste c'est une espèce comment
dirais-je de l'égocentrisme et des
nombrilisme jusqu'à la folie meurt entre
nous le président actuel aussi poser
problème
oui enfin un art sicile dix ans sur
narcisse y est la preuve qu'on avait
raison
c'est quand même la façon dont il ne
peut pas accepter qu'il y ait un autre
président de son propre camp
y'a pas
élus de droite aujourd'hui qui
prétendrait qu'on a eu tort de dire ça
parce qu'ils viennent de découvrir qu'on
avait besoin c'est que sarkozy a empêché
ça je peux empêcher mais ça lui est
impossible il a encore une fois il a des
grandes qualités c'est vital car aucun
quelqu'un d'autre à droite peut être
président lui est insupportable vous
avez là d'enduro c'est avec avec la
gauche 1 vous vous écrivait par exemple
en 1986 la gauche perd les élections
législatives sous françois mitterrand à
ce moment là c'était pas déshonorant à
les scores étaient bien plus important
qu'aujourd'hui mais vous dites au fond
il se remet jamais en question une se
demande jamais pourquoi il a perdu ce
parti-là et quarante ans plus tard avec
entre 2 et 6 % ils ne se demandent
toujours pas pourquoi il en est là voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui se passe à droite la gauche
d'ailleurs c'est étonnant ça m'a
toujours eu c'est à dire à un moment
dire mais quelle erreur on l'a fait il
ya un type par exemple s'appelle ben ami
européen je connais pas ou très mal mais
ça me fascine pourquoi c'est le premier
café 8 % aux élections européennes 8% la
droite j % qui aurait imaginé que la
droite à dire la fusion du giscardisme
et du gaullisme la droite unie 8% depuis
elle a fait pire mais 8% des faits et
bien écoutez quand il parle non
seulement il n'a jamais analyser
pourquoi j'ai fait 8% mais quand il
s'exprime il donne des leçons implacable
à vous devez faire ça ou ne pas faire
assez incroyable tripartisme et trois
blocs on lit ça partout vous pensez que
ça va durer moi je crois que je vais
vous dire je crois que oui à trois blocs
on l'a vu le temps où il y en a ils vont
éclater la plupart mans faille pour
l'instant il ya d'ailleurs il ya trois
blocs de toute façon je suis convaincu
je suis convaincue mais ça dépend de
nous tous tu que va renaître une vraie
droite libérale ouverte démocratique
républicaine comme on dit et que va
finir par reconnaître une gauche laïque
démocratique
c'est avec des hommes nouveaux un
langage de vous j'en suis absolument
convaincu pour l'instant ce à quoi on
assiste et qui peut provoquer des
surprises aux élections qu'on va vivre
c'est le nom de convergences possibles
entre l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite
transition vous allez voir vous allez
voir au deuxième tour dans beaucoup de
circonscriptions
quand vous aurez un maquereau nice tu
fasses un mélenchonistes pour qui va
voter
vous regardez bien à regarder on va
scruter ces reconstitutions
si les extrêmes moi je suis très
préoccupé par ça parce que on parle
toujours la gauche a abusé du terme
fascistes fascistes fascistes assis
fasciste c'est pal extrêmement entrepôt
est ultra religieux ultra libérale dans
les pachys le fascisme scientifiquement
c'est la conjonction extrême droite
extrême gauche ces salles cheese et vous
d'ailleurs vous allé alerter déjà là
dessus depuis des années dans vos
journaux vous en parlez aussi dans votre
livre vous rester avec moi jean françois
k mémoire d'autres vie tome 2 malgré
tout on l'a fait on l'a dit point
d'exclamation ça parle aussi de votre
amour de la musique de vos émissions
chanter le mois on avait une archive à
vous montrer malheureusement n'a pas le
temps parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir et bien aux deux
chroniqueuses ce soir pour cette page
sur les législatives qu'on va ouvrir à
présent à moins de deux semaines du
premier tour on va accueillir céline
bracq de l'institut au doxa pour son
baromètre du mois de mai baromètre
politique mensuel et puis l amont d'un
gamin de la rédaction des steppers bien
sûr pour son carnet de campagne les 577
et tout de suite bonsoir mes bas mon
soir les législatives vous commenciez à
nous en parler jean françois kahn céline
on commence avec vous vous nous révéler
comme chaque mois le baromètre aux docks
ça on commence avec le couple exécutif
alors au mois de mai la cote de
popularité des manuels macron et de
elisabeth bornes ne sont pas on va dire
dithyrambiques c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire pas ou plus aux 56 %
d'impopularité pour le président réélu
on l'a vu s'afficher il ya un instant
56% d'impopularité donc ferait un bon
président non et puis pour la première
ministre la toute nouvelle première
ministre c'est
55% d'impopularité pour un nouveau
mandat quand même c'est surprenant c'est
même état de grâce c'est même un record
en fait pour un nouveau mandat alors
puisqu'on 44 % de popularité on se dit
bon après tout c'est normal parce que
c'est un c'est un second mandat c'est
par un c'est pas comme si c'est un tout
nouveau président mais si il se compare
macro il ne se consolera pas puisque si
on voit où on était mitterrand en 81 8
pour son second mandat il est à 65 % il
démarre avec une cote de popularité très
forte et jacques chirac il est à 52 %
donc quand même eu points de plus qu
emmanuel macron et on a des perceptions
qui sont toujours très contrasté avec
d'un côté des sympathisants renaissance
qui adore le président de la république
des sympathisants des partis qu'on dit
modéré lr parti socialiste qu'il aime
bien on est au-dessus des 50% et puis
vraiment des sympathisants des autres
formations ceux qui sont aux extrêmes
qui on rejette complètement le président
de la république et vous l'avez dit il
n'ya pas d'état de grâce non plus pour
elisabeth bornes pour elle aussi c'est
celle qui démarre le plus bas pour une
premier ministre avec 43 % de popularité
alors elle est pas très loin de raffarin
en 2002 de fillon en 2007 qui étaient
autour de 45%
alors il ya autre chose aussi c'est que
le côté femme de gauche c'est beaucoup
comme ça qu'on l'a présenté disons que
ça parle pas tellement dans l'opinion
sur la fibre sociale est ce que pour le
moment il est à l'isolément des plus
appréciés des sympathisants l air que
des sympathisants du parti socialiste ou
d'europe écologie les verts alors ça ne
joue pas beaucoup à 4,6 points mais elle
est plus appréciée à droite qu'à gauche
alors on nous la page de l'initiative ça
c'est pour l'exécutif mais c'est très
lié forcément on est à moins de deux
semaines des législatives
on peut se dit ah bon c'est souvent un
scrutin qu'ils allaient va mobiliser un
peu moins voire beaucoup moins qu'à la
présidentielle mais là franchement 33 %
seulement sont intéressés par ce scrutin
s'est peu à peu c'est peu et ça augure
probablement d'une participation à ces
élections qui sera faible puisque quand
on regarde notre indicateur de
participation on est à 47 % de
participation est donc à 53 %
d'abstention on pourrait donc battre le
record de 2010 est je vous rappelle
qu'on était à 48,7 % de participation au
premier tour alors c'est pas sûr non
plus parce qu'il ya des marges d'erreur
on est grosso modo on se dit entre 43 %
et 50 % de participation mais ce sera
probablement une des participations les
plus faibles de la vème république avec
comme à l'accoutumée des jeunes et les
foyers les plus modestes qui nous disent
le plus qui devraient s'abstenir et
en particulier de l'abstention du coup
pour jean luc mélenchon pour marine le
pen sans doute puisque ce sont des
électorats qui se susurre mobilisent
quand ils votent pour hausser pour ces
deux candidats françois kahn on est dans
la drôle de moment quand même ce trait
d'union entre woods ancien les
législatives sur les 40 % dont il est
juste et de toute façon ça fait
plusieurs années depuis que macro et là
quasiment où les sens d'un gilet je ne
connais pas il n'y a pas eu un seul sans
ajout étaient majoritaires à ma
connaissance non été au toit s'il était
au tout début à haut débit
à partir de chez moi il a toujours été
minoritaire minoritaires minoritaire
mais vous faire attention dans la
lecture parce que si en effet c'est un
sondage qu'on lit comme on lisait il ya
huit ans il n'a aucune chance de gagner
les élections ah oui et non
aucun président qui faisait 40 personne
n'a jamais gagné les élections sauf que
là c'est mon attention il a contrôlé la
droite il a contre lui l'extrême droite
il a contre lui la gauche il a construit
et l'extrême gauche il a contre lui une
partie du centre donc on peut se dire
mais où ils les trouvent ces 40% ce
fossile ya aussi chez téthys est un
prochain et comme les autres ne peuvent
pas s'entendre entre eux ben oui on peut
gagner une élection à 40% mais
législatives donc abstention importante
c'est une tendance de fond mais c'est
plus grave avec cette élection là oui
parce qu en réalité ça s'érode depuis 93
mais on a eu une dégringolade en 2017
puisqu'on avait moins de 50% je les dis
juste avant de participation et on était
encore à 57% en 2012 goyer -7 entre 2012
et 2017 et surtout en 2017 on va voir ce
que ça donne là mais on a eu beaucoup
plus de votants intermittents c'est
comme ça que les appels l'insee c'est à
dire que normalement c'est un peu un lot
la présidentielle puis les législatives
ya quatre tours mais les actes les
électeurs ont nettement moins voté que
par le passé à l'ensemble des tours
et des élections présidentielle et
législatives ils étaient encore 5 sur 10
en 2002 en 2007 en 2012 à voter ou
quatre tours et ils étaient moins de
quatre sur dix en 2010 est donc si vous
voulez le vote systématique baisse et ce
que l'on voit notre sondage c'est que
les français ne comprennent pas trop
bien pourquoi ils devraient après avoir
voté à la présidentielle votez en plus
pour les législateurs d'un tout petit
mot il ya une chose que les français ont
bien identifié ce sont les leaders
d'opposition dans cette campagne des
législatives
j'ai nommé jean-luc mélenchon et marine
le pen mais quand on regarde décote
d'adhésion voilà sa basse aussi et pour
marine le pen - 3 points à 35% et pour
jean luc mélenchon
29% mois ces points oui c'est à dire que
ils demeurent les leaders à gauche et à
droite ces deux là mais ce que l'on voit
dans nous quand on fait les codes
d'adhésion si qui sont très loin du
chouchou que actuelle et depuis des mois
dans l'opinion qui edouard philippe qui
lui est à 47 % donc vous voyez 35% pour
marine le pen 29 % jean-luc mélenchon et
en plus les deux sont les personnalités
sont dans le top 5 des personnalités les
plus rejeter donc ça on le voit est
derrière ces personnalités qui sont très
clivante ils sont en rouge est largement
tous la majorité jeu là je les passe
sous les yeux je peux vous répondre mais
en rouge elle m'a alors assuré l'agent
par mélenchon avec pardon je dis une
bêtise 47% de roger 45% pour marine le
pen derrière eric zemmour anne hidalgo
et valérie pécresse
vraiment veut dire quand même je termine
juste que en fait malgré son
impopularité c'est ce que vous disiez
jean françois kahn finalement son
opposition et elle est essentiellement
composé de personnalités très clivante
de retraité de la politique avec
françois hollande par exemple qui est 8e
et de personnalité vraiment pas à la
pudeur ça relativise les choses garde
votre mot de conclusion s'il reste une
poignée de secondes mais je voudrais
qu'on écoute elle va jean françois kahn
vous nous parler ce soir d'un corps l on
va encore esther des présidents de la
république est justement on y retrouve
un ancien chef de l'état oui françois
hollande est en déplacement hier c'était
dont une à qu'il était avec
bernard cazeneuve qui avait été je le
rappelle son ministre de l'intérieur et
son premier ministre officiellement il
venait défendre une candidate une
candidate dissidente face à la
candidature de la nuque meba
officieusement y venaient surtout
dézinguer la nuque la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale écoutez
il y à des circonscriptions 500 où il
n'y a pas de candidat socialiste
odon d'union qui s'est construite
davantage par l'effacement que par
l'affirmation et sur un programme qui ne
correspond pas à la crédibilité qui est
attendu pour une éventuelle future
majorité des socialistes ont déposé tous
leurs bagages et se sont précipités de
façon moutonnière et grégaire vers le
grand méchant loup qui me menacer de les
manger tout cru et ils l'ont fait avec
une solution
absolue à mouthe aunis mme total un
grégarisme assumait ils se sont
comportés comme des voyageurs sans
bagages c'est très dommage puisque la
politique n'est pas un exercice qu'on
conduit en courbant l'échiné voilà
hollande et 15,9 soutiennent les
candidats dissidents donc qui ne sont
pas dans la nuque mais qui sont
socialiste tout comme carole delga en
occitanie exactement la chef de la
région occitania elle a pris un petit
peu la tête aussi de ces dissidents il
souhaite les fédérer elle n'accepte pas
cette soumission aux insoumis il ya deux
camps qui semblent s'affronter donc
entre les candidats de la nuque et les
dissidences et pas forcément si simple
parce qu'on peut être candidat de la
nuque soutenu par carole delga on verra
si les électeurs un siècle alors moi
j'ai voilà j'ai déjà du mal alors c'est
dire vous vous trouvez que les
socialistes ont raison d'aller en
décidant ce d'un mot au nom je les dis
voulait montrer non je dis simplement
dire deux choses l'une vous avez
aujourd'hui ou bien un phénomène ben
vous l'avez très bien dit anti macron
importe qui peut faire provoque une
convergence du vote le pen mélenchon
dans ce cas la macro fallait les imac
sinon vous avez vous allez très fort
c'est tout sauf merci mélenchon et à ce
moment là les maths religieuse merci
beaucoup jean françois kahn
vous revenez quand vous voulez mais de
voir d'autres vies cet os édition de
l'observatoire c'est la fin de cette
émission tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire avec un film sur le lobby
du tabac à 1953 l'industrie du mensonge
mais avant de se quitter la chaîne
parlementaire tient à adresser ses
condoléances à la famille de frédéric
leclerc imhoff notre confrères de bfm tv
tu es en ukraine alors qu'il filmait la
fuite de civils à bord d'un convoi
humanitaire nous pensons évidemment à
ses proches et à sa rédaction bouleversé
bonne soirée à demain
[Musique]